>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> John Van Oudenaren:
Good evening.
My name is John Van Oudenaren.
I'm the Director for Scholarly
and Educational Programs here
at the Library of Congress.
I met some of you
the other evening
when you were just
arriving, those of you
from the Rare Book School,
I did meet some of you
and others of you I haven't met.
I'm here to introduce our
distinguished speaker.
Michael F. Suarez, S.J.
has served as Director
of the Rare Book School,
Professor of English,
University Professor,
and Honorary Curator
of Special Collections
at the University
of Virginia since 2009.
He has many degrees.
I actually had to have a little
tutorial out in the hallway
about how to say
some of these degrees
but he received a D.Phil., a
Master of Studies and an MA/BA
from Oxford University, a
Master of Theology and a Master
of Divinity from the Weston
Jesuit School of Theology,
and a B.A. from Bucknell
University.
He has written widely
on various aspects
of 18th-century English
literature, bibliography
and book history and he has
held research fellowships
from the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study
at Harvard University,
the National Endowment
for the Humanities, the American
Council of Learned Societies,
and the Folger Shakespeare
Library.
He is a CLIR, that's
Council on Library
and Information Resources,
C-L-I-R,
he is a CLIR Distinguished
Presidential Fellow,
member of the Advisory
Board of Library
of Congress Literacy
Awards Program,
the Council of the
Bibliographical Society
of America, and the
Board of Managers
of the Lewis Walpole
Library at Yale University.
So he comes with
great credentials
and an enormous amount of
experience and knowledge.
Since 2010, he has
served as editor-in-chief
of Oxford Scholarly
Editions Online.
His recent books include "The
Cambridge History of the Book
in Britain," Volume five,
1695-1830, obviously published
by Cambridge University
Press, which is co-edited
with Michael Turner, and
"The Oxford Companion
to the Book" published by
Oxford University Press,
a million-word reference book
co-edited with H. R. Woudhuysen.
"The Book: A Global
History," also co-edited
with H. R. Woudhuysen,
first appeared in 2013.
In 2014, Oxford University
Press published his edition
of "The Dublin Notebook,"
co-edited with Lesley Higgins,
in the "Collected Works
of Gerard Manley Hopkins."
He delivered the 2015 Lyell
Lectures in Bibliography
at the University of Oxford.
So with that introduction,
Father Suarez, we look forward
to hearing you talk about
the business of abridgments
in 18th-century Britain
and America.
Thank you.
>> Michael Suarez:
Thank you, John.
[ Applause ]
We probably don't need
the waiver on the podium.
I know the federal government
is interested in the legality
but we can probably
put that to the side.
So today I'd like to talk to
you little bit about the world
of abridgments and, indeed,
I'd like to establish
with you the ubiquity of
abridgments in the 18th century.
I think it's not too much to
say that the reprint trade
in the 18th century is
the trade in abridgments
and I'll explain why
as we continue on.
So first I'd like to begin
with a small post octavo
that you see on your screens.
This is Ortelius, his
great atlas done in octavo.
This is 1601 and by no means
the first of these abridgments,
there's an antecedent
abridgment in 1577.
And I adduce this because
the abridgment isn't invented
in the 18th century.
That would be fatuous to
think so, but the rhetoric
of the abridgment is very
much part and parcel here
of what will be in
our own century.
Somehow this is smaller,
more portable, more useful,
that's how it's being marketed,
and there's always a
rhetoric of value added.
So in this case there is a star
map and two other maps added one
of Formosa that aren't
in the original
and so the idea is get this and
you'll be able to have things
that you wouldn't be able to get
in the full big trophy atlas.
It's also true that many of you
will know from studying Ortelius
that that book was seldom used.
It's a gentlemen's
trophy book in many ways.
Whereas if you, as I have,
make a comprehensive study
as best you can of the surviving
abridgments from '77 and '01,
these post-octavos show many
more signs of actual use.
Many of you will know the
story told by Daniel Defoe
who went hold up for five years
while writing his great poetic
treatise on the divine right
of kings, "Jure Divino,"
a book in 375 pages
folio, a book that cost
without the frontispiece
the whopping sum in 1706
of 10 shillings and with the
frontispiece in which Defoe is,
as you can see, big
wigged, it's 13 shillings.
Okay? This is Defoe wanting to
become the next John Dryden.
Okay? He fails.
And on the day that the
folio was published,
the very same day Defoe
discovers he was betrayed
by someone in his own
printers printing office
and exactly concomitantly the
down market version in octavo
of this book comes
out selling not for 13
with the frontispiece,
not for 10
without the frontispiece,
but for 5 shillings.
Defoe himself says, I lost 1500
pounds because of the piracy,
and people often think
because they know the octavo,
it survives in large
numbers that it's
because of the publication
of this octavo.
This, ladies and gentlemen,
is by no means the case.
The octavo hurt him.
He had to lower his price,
but the real couplet are the
halfpenny and penny abridgments.
And this is an example
of one of those.
You can see the incredible
page depth,
the number of lines
per page here.
You can see how closely printed
it is and there's the idea is
that there's one either full
sheet or half sheet number
for each of the 12 books.
These are very rare now because
they were little pamphlets.
They're very hard to find
in any concentrated numbers
to study bibliographically.
But let's look at what
the advertisements say.
You can get the 12
books of "Jure Divino,"
which had been 13 shillings
and then came down to 5
because he had to
compete with the octavo.
Thank you very much.
You can get it now in
halfpenny parts on the left
or in penny parts on the
right, depending upon
if it's a half sheet
or whole sheet.
So you can get the whole
of "Jure Divino" not
for 13 shillings, not for 10
shillings, not for 5 shillings,
but for 12 pence or 6 pence.
While it's not the
whole, it's the epitome.
Yeah. It's the abridgment.
And this is the attitude that
I had toward abridgments.
This is what I knew
abridgments were.
I had made a study of Defoe
and I knew about Hills,
the black friars pirate
and what he had done
and this is exactly
what an abridgment was
in the 18th century, I
felt certain, but I decided
to inquire a little bit
further and I read the work
of a man named Jordan Howell
in the library an article I
recommend to you most strongly.
And Mr. Howell for his doctoral
dissertation made a study
of the abridgments
of "Robinson Crusoe."
And here's what he discovered;
75% of the "Robinson
Crusoe" titles published
in the 18th century
are abridgments;
75% of the titles
are abridgments.
That's a breathtaking thing.
And as we'll see,
Crusoe abridgments appear
in a disproportionate way.
Now this is partly because
we know "Robinson Crusoe"
as one book, whereas "Robinson
Crusoe" is really three books.
Okay? First, there's the story
of Robinson Crusoe that we know.
Then there's the strange
and surprising adventures
and finally there's serious
reflection on the life
and history of Robinson Crusoe
and so these volumes together
make up a three-volume set
and this is very long and I
can tell you the third volume
in particular kind of
boring, lots of reflections
on particular providence, not
many things moving very quickly.
And so this gets abridged
and abridged and abridged.
Well, very well.
None of these abridgments
were authorized.
And again, I thought this
must be akin to what happened
to Defoe with "Jure Divino."
And then I start to look still
more closely into the world
of abridgments and I saw
that one John Wesley,
the founder of Methodism, who
didn't seem like very much
of a rapscallion to me,
certainly not akin to Hills,
the black friars pirate.
I saw that in '48 he abridged
"Pilgrim's Progress" and that
that one by '66 is
in a fifth edition.
And I thought, oh, very well.
He does this because he
has a religious purpose
and they leave them alone
because obviously this
must be actionable.
And then I went in and I
saw some more Wesley books
and I was astonished,
"The Manners
of the Ancient Christians"
is in the fifth edition.
It's an abridgment.
Nicodemus, "A Treatise on the
Fear of Man, The Life of God
and the Soul of Man" and you
can see at the bottom one
of the keys to Wesley's
success, printed and sold
at the New Chapel City Road
and at the Reverend Mr. Wesley's
preaching houses in Town
and Country and here we
see a distribution network.
And on further inquiry,
with the help of ESTC
and a little digging, I discover
that John Wesley is the
greatest abridger in the history
of the 18th century and that
he's responsible for more
than 100 titles being abridged,
about 600 editions in all.
And I thought to myself, gosh, I
wonder if Wesley was ever taken
to court for any of these
because he doesn't seem
like a man who would
willfully break the law.
And I found out that the
only time he ever ran
into any trouble at
all was when in one
of his volumes he reprinted
parts of "Night Thoughts"
which was in the
copyright of Robert Dodsley.
And Dodsley came
to him and said,
that's mine, thank
you very much.
And they settled the matter
completely out of court.
Wesley gave him 20 pounds and
promised not to do it again
and that seemed to be
okay for everybody.
But searching the records of
the law courts in England,
Wesley is never, never, never,
numquam, numquam, numquam,
ever brought to court for
any of these abridgments.
We'll soon see why.
So let's pause for a
moment here and try
to understand why
abridgments are
so ubiquitous in
the 18th century.
For the most part, a
pamphlet costs between 6 pence
and 18 pence and you can
see that newspapers are
about 3 pence, novels un-sewn
are 2 and 6, or 3 shillings
if they're in trade
bindings, and octavos are
about 5 shillings a volume.
This is a lot of money.
And books are luxury commodities
throughout the century.
And unless we understand that,
we won't really understand
the world
of abridgments although
there's a lot more to say.
A little consumer price index
information to try to help you
out so you understand, well
how much is 5 shillings,
how much is 3 shillings, and
you could say that you see
that a bushel of
coal is 14 pence.
A pound of wheat
is 1 and 3/4 pence.
Okay? An annual rent
for a laborer,
1 pound 8 shillings
and twopence.
And with the cost of all
his utilities as it were,
his heating, it's about
3 pounds per annum, yeah,
2 and 1/2 pounds per annum.
So when we start to think
about what books cost,
we see the books are
indeed luxury commodities.
There's more to be
told still, however.
So Samuel Johnson himself
in Rambler 145 tells us
that some readers delight
in abstracts and epitomes
and I think other than money,
the most powerful resource
that people have is time.
And so we shouldn't just
imagine that the only people
who are reading abridgments
are people who are too poor
to buy the full thing
because maybe you just want
to get the gist of it and
move on, maybe you just want
to be able to say
sure I read that.
Right? So this is
kind of interesting.
So when we think about
why abridgments are
on the one hand everywhere
and on the other hand have been
bibliographically invisible
to us, I think that we need
to think about two things.
The first of these is the
cultures of collecting.
Do you really think
that with the formation
of the principal cultural
institutions of England
and America in the 19th century
that those institutions
were collecting the piracies
of "Robinson Crusoe?"
Do you really think that they
were collecting the abridgments
of Locke and Hume?
Why would they?
They're not the "real thing."
They're not the first editions.
They haven't received any
bibliographical treatment.
There are no points.
And so you can imagine that
the culture of collecting
in the 19th century right
through the 20th century is one
in which the abridgment
is pretty much invisible.
That's the first thing.
The second thing to bear
in mind is survival rates,
ladies and gentlemen.
It is true that survival
rates are not entirely
stochastic processes.
Sure, sometimes there's a flood.
Sometimes there's a fire.
And whatever is in its wake
is going to be destroyed.
But it's also true that
smaller books have a lower
survival rate.
Unbound books have a
much lower survival rate.
The unbound book does not
survive is a good rule of thumb.
If you're buying the small
abridgment, is that rather akin
to buying the paperback?
So then why would you bother
to pay to have it bound?
Right? But we also need
to remember Roger Stoddard's
law, which goes like this.
Roger Stoddard, the brilliant
bibliographer and curator
at Harvard University for so
many years, informs us, rightly,
bigger books linger longer,
little books last least.
While these abridgments are
little books per force both
in their formats,
duodecimos and 16 mos,
some of them even 32 mos,
but they're also little books
in the sense that they
have low sheet count.
Right? So these are the books
that are likely to
last the least.
The cultures of collecting
determine
that they're not important,
they're not the "real McCoy"
and they're going to be unbound.
They're not sold
in trade bindings.
And they're little books that
are very likely to last least.
So the survival rates
are extremely low.
And yet we know Samuel
Johnson was an abridger.
Tobias Smollett was an abridger.
Oliver Goldsmith was abridger.
You get the idea, right?
There a lot of people
who we regard
as pretty high-end authors who
are employed by the booksellers
to do the business of
creating these abridgments,
in part because over time their
names carry with them a kind
of authorizing cultural capital.
So this is a very preliminary
bibliometric analysis
of the English Short
Title Catalogue.
And you can see, ladies
and gentlemen, for this,
all I did was look at titles
that announce themselves
as abridgments or epitomes.
So there are no silent
abridgments in this count at all
and there are many other ways to
talk about what an abridgment is
than just say on the title
page, abridgment or epitome.
Right?
So here you see the vast
number of abridgments.
If you run out to the store
right now and go by volume five
of the Cambridge history
of the book in Britain,
I say completely disinterestedly
and look at the chapter
on bibliometric analysis, you
will see that this profile here
of the abridgments bears a
remarkably close correspondence
to the productive output
of the century itself.
In other words, the proportions
stay alarmingly closely the
same, almost to the
degree that it looks
like I cooked the
books, which I haven't
and this is part of
an ongoing study.
This is work in progress.
You saw it here first.
So if we look by title at some
of the most important
abridgments,
here you see Robinson Crusoe
is a complete outlier,
but then you start to see
these are just abridgments
and I won't read it to you.
You can read for which you
should thank a teacher every day
but you see that overwhelmingly
religious books are highly
abridged among the
bestsellers of abridged books,
but also voyages as well,
dictionaries and so on.
So here is a breakdown by genre.
As I say, these results
are preliminary
but you can see the profound
abridgment of religious books,
fiction, and historical books.
Okay? So that just gives
you a little bit of the lay
of the land and gives a
little evidence to my argument
for this ubiquity of
abridgments in the 18th century.
Why? Remarkably, because
the Lord Chancellor himself
in Gyles v Wilcox in 1741 ruled
that a thoughtful abridgment
is protected by law.
That is to say if I take Mark
[inaudible] immortal book
that you will all have read
Beach Blanket Bibliography,
I know you know this
classical text,
and if I take Beach
Blanket Bibliography
and merely reprint
the first 200 pages,
that is not a thoughtful
abridgment
and that is actionable.
There can be an injunction
issued right away prohibiting
the vending of that product.
But if I make what's called
in the law a judicious
or thoughtful abridgment,
and I actually go through
and make careful selection
and epitome as it were,
of what Mark has written, then
mirabile dictu, very foreign
to our modern sensibility
that is protected
under the law according
to no less an authority
than the Lord Chancellor
himself.
This is a remarkable thing
and this legal doctrine helps
to explain why the reprint trade
is the trade in the abridgments.
Boswell said to Johnson,
this is ridiculous,
this is like taking the ears or
the horns and the tail off a cow
and calling it a new thing and
trying to sell it as a new cow.
And Johnson says,
nonsense, Boswell.
It's like making
the cow have a calf.
So you will remember that
the act for the encouragement
of learning is about the
preservation of good copies
in order to help the public
be informed and learned.
And so were Lord Chief Justice,
Lord Chancellor Hardwicke rules
that the judicious abridgment
is protected under law
because he sees it as being
commensurate with the act
of Queen Anne because it's
in the public interest.
It's an act not merely for
profit but for the public good.
And then when the booksellers
come back at this again
and you have Bell versus
Walker and [inaudible],
again in 1785 the Master of
the Rolls writing the opinion
for the Lord Chancellor again
reinforces the idea, remarkably,
that of thoughtful abridgment
is non-injunctionable.
This is a remarkable thing and
so it's protected under law.
So it's all very well for us to
say, ha, I've read "Tom Jones."
I know how long that book is.
Look at thin little volume.
This isn't "Tom Jones."
But here's the question:
What does the presence
of this book printed and
reprinted in the market do
to our understanding of
the reception history
of Fielding and of this novel?
It's no good for us to get on
our high horses and to say,
well, that just isn't
"Tom Jones."
If more people read "Tom
Jones" in abridgments
or if more people certainly
read "Robinson Crusoe"
in abridgments, then
what's the real McCoy?
Do you see?
So bibliography is now
confounding our sense
of the reception history that
we thought we knew all too well.
So here we have the history
of "Sir Charles Grandison"
in 170 duodecimo pages.
This is absurd in some
ways, but if you've read
"Sir Charles Grandison,"
you are grateful.
I am deeply grateful
for the abridgment.
And it's all very well
for us to say, oh,
but this isn't Richardson.
Well, in some ways it is
and in some ways it isn't.
It's all very well
for us to complain.
Well, epistolarity is lost.
Yes, epistolarity is lost.
But if this is what
a significant portion
of the population is reading,
then we must countenance this
as a liminal moment in the
reception history of this work.
And so once again,
bibliographical history
judiciously done informs
and re-informs the conduct
of literary history.
Here is a book that I discovered
was on the cart for our class
on the book in the 18th century.
You see in the middle this is
a Library of Congress book.
Sterne is dead by the
time this book comes out.
This is a Dublin reprint of
"Tristram Shandy," which as many
of you will know is
a bestselling book
in nine volumes, and this is
the whole of "Tristram Shandy"
in three small octavo volumes.
Why? Not only because it's
cheaper but please understand
if I'm a bookseller, even in
Dublin where I can't be touched
by the idea of the
laws of piracy,
it's extremely risky undertaking
for me to produce nine volumes
of Laurence Sterne, even though
I already know he's a bestseller
because that's all lot of paper.
That's a lot of typesetting.
Right? And that's
a big investment
on the part of the audience.
But if I can commission someone
to abridge "Tristram Shandy"
into a limited number of sheets,
then my abridgment can be
calibrated to the capital risk
that I can afford
and my judgment
of the carrying capacity
of my local market.
So now all of a sudden
I'm not imprisoned
by Sterne's prolixity.
I can do what I want
to do and say, well,
this is about as many sheets
as I could handle in terms
of the capital expenditure
at this edition size.
And so I can calculate
in advance how long I want
the abridgment to be and then
when I commission John to do
the abridgment, it has to come
in at a certain number of sheets
or indeed a certain word count
or if I'm the printer I
think about it in terms
of a certain number of
[inaudible] perhaps and now all
of a sudden I've ameliorated my
capital risk and I've been able
to make a locally informed
judgment about my resources
and the carrying
capacity of the market.
And so all of a sudden if we
start to study abridgments
in these ways, we can give a
local habitation and a name --
That's an original phrase
that I just thought up.
We can give a local
habitation and a name
to the carrying capacity
of particular markets,
at particular moments
in history,
because we can see how
many sheets the different
abridgments are.
They could be as
long or as short
as the bookseller
wants them to be.
They're not at the
mercy of anybody.
This is another Library
of Congress book.
This is "Clarissa."
This is Hartford, Connecticut,
and here this book is 138
pages, which is remarkable.
"Clarissa," as you remember, is
a book eight volumes and seven.
"Clarissa" costs those
3 shillings times seven.
Last time I checked,
3 times 7 is 21.
And last time I checked,
21 shillings is the guinea.
A guinea is a boatload of money.
Right? Hartford,
Connecticut isn't going
to pay the equivalent of
a guinea for eight volumes
of "Clarissa" and no
local bookseller can bear
that capital risk.
And the productive capacity
of his press just
can't handle that.
So what does he do?
He makes "Clarissa"
into 138 pages
because that's what
the market will bear
and that's what his
capital expenditure can do.
So all these books
are, therefore, bespoke
and because they're
bespoke in a different way
than when Henry Fielding goes
to Andrew Miller and says, here,
I had a bestseller in "Tom
Jones" and now I'm giving you
"Amelia" and this is what it is.
Now, the thing that
Miller has control
over is the edition quantity,
which in the case of "Amelia,"
he got wrong and it took
him ten years to sell
out the edition quantity he
printed because "Tom Jones" had
to be so often reprinted
but, nevertheless,
Miller's at the mercy of what
the author brings to him.
In this case, that's
not so [inaudible].
And so these books allow us to
undertake certain diagnostics
of the local and
the provincial trade
that we could never conduct
in other ways before.
So here's Oliver Goldsmith,
who made a fortune abridging.
He got $500 for producing
the "History of England"
in two volumes, which
is just in abridgment
of four antecedent works
and combining them.
And then, of course, he
abridges the abridgment.
We know we have his surviving
agreement for his abridgment
of the "Roman History"
for which he got 52 pounds
and 10 shillings.
This is remarkable.
So abridging is good work.
And the reason why abridging
is the work for Goldsmith is
because he's a celebrity by
this juncture and his name
on the title page authorizes
what's been done to the text.
And this is really important and
Tom Davies is willing to pay him
that kind of money up
front and more if it runs,
precisely because the
world of abridgment,
the market is always
stratified and so the world
of abridgment is going to
hit the stratified market
at a place that's new
territory for that book
and Davies wants
to get in on it.
So what kinds of
books are abridged?
Well, the "World of Voyages" is
extremely popular in England.
And so you see this consortium
of booksellers, the Dodsley,
Rivington, Fletcher, Johnson,
Strawn, and Jeffreys come
out with this compendium of
"Voyages" in seven volumes.
And in the preface
they say, gosh,
there are so many
collections of "Voyages"
but you know they're
full of dross
and we're doing you a
great favor by taking
out the technicalities
of navigation
and all the boring bits.
And we'll just give
you the best parts.
And besides, who could
afford all those books?
There was those big folios,
those large quartos, but here,
these are companionable volumes
and we are doing, oh yes,
a tremendous service
to the public
because we are letting you
have the best of the best
at a price you can
afford, gentle reader.
And so Tobias Smollett is one
of the principal abridgers
on this project,
thank you very much.
And this runs to
the second edition.
What kind of books get abridged?
Oh, Foxe's "Book of
Martyrs" gets abridged over
and over and over again.
Foxe's "Book of Martyrs," of
course under Foxe gets bigger
and bigger and bigger.
In the 18th century, it
gets smaller and smaller
and smaller, to some degree.
I can tell you neither of
these editions of Foxe,
1760 which is really
'61 and then again '66,
neither of these editions
of Foxe tell you they're
an abridgment anywhere.
They just say, hi, here's Foxe.
And I can also tell you because
I was able to check the sheets
in the Bodleian Library,
these are indeed two
completely different printings.
And so that's interesting
to know
that the market will bear that.
So Johnson's dictionary, 1755,
we all know that the
English were so proud
because it only takes
one Englishman
to do what the entire French
Academy could not accomplish.
And so that's wonderful.
And of course that's two
volumes folio, a massive work,
1500 copies printed and
in Johnson's lifetime,
in the 29 years from
when the first edition
of the dictionary comes out
until Johnson's death in 1784,
hey, 5000 copies of those four
editions of the folio come out
and that's pretty great.
Only somewhere between 35,000
copies and 40,000 copies
of the octavo abridgment made
by Johnson himself in service
of the common reader sell.
So now, what's Johnson's
dictionary
and how would you know?
It we're asking about the
dictionary as monument,
it's those twin pillars of
lexicography, the folios.
If we're asking how did
Johnson's much-vaunted common
reader employ the dictionary,
it's got to be the octavos.
Yeah? But this is a way of
conducting literary history
and reception history that is
heretofore very little practice
because we haven't yet done
the bibliographical homework
in a thoroughgoing way.
Bibliography and book history
is meant to make us more knowing
so that we can do history
more authentically.
And here is one of a
number of examples.
Of course, the abridger
himself is repeatedly abridged.
Here are the first 20 some
odd lives of the poets,
all compassed into
roughly 100 pages in, yes,
an abridgment of
Johnson's "Lives."
It's also true that abridgments
will come out when you want
to limit your capital risk but
when you also want to capitalize
on a dormant capital resource.
So here we have the
micrographia and the plates
to the micrographia still
exist, Hooke's original plates
and so what are they
going to do?
Well, micrographia
ristorante, of course.
So we're going to use
the plates and turn them
into an active capital
resource instead
of a dormant capital resource.
We're going to reprint
all the plates
but note the rhetoric
of the abridgment.
This renders the present volume
so small though it really
contains the whole sense of all
that is necessary fully to
understand the following plates.
In fact, it's even better
because we will take
what was abstruse
and make it clear, dear reader.
This is cheaper,
better, stronger, faster.
You would think this
was American.
So this is very typical.
Take a capital resource and
repurpose it but repurpose it
in such a way that you're
not risking too much.
So here you see the famous
play that everybody knows.
And then there is this
chap named George Kearsley.
And if we want to understand
the culture of abridgments,
we also need to understand
the culture of excerpting,
which is rampant in
the 18th century.
The culture of publishing
beauties,
the culture of publishing
elegant extracts,
the famous [inaudible] books
which are meant to be books
to teach people oratory
and rhetoric but really are
read as books of the beauties
or excerpts of the major poets
and playwrights of the time.
And here is the beauties
of Laurence Sterne
for half a crown, two
shillings and sixpence,
thank you very much,
and I, George Kearsley,
will just happen to remind you
that this book is not related to
but may be occasioned
by the fact
that Sterne's works have
just come out in ten volumes
at the outrageous
price of two guineas.
So here you can either pay
half a crown or two guineas.
What are you going to do?
A guinea is 21 shillings.
So 42 shillings or two
shillings and sixpence.
What do you want to do?
What's in your wallet?
So it turns out that Kearsley
has this interesting habit,
this is from the
Bodleian Library,
and he engineers the third,
fourth, and fifth edition
to come one every month but
it's all the same sheets.
He changes the title page
in the early preliminaries
so you can't tell.
But if you line them up
and fingerprint the sheets,
as I have been deeply
privileged to do
in [inaudible], what
do you discover?
You discover that those
sheets, the inner form
and the outer form of every
sheet is exactly identical.
Thank you very much.
And what's he trying to do?
He's trying to get
momentum for the book.
He's trying to make the book
a fashionable commodity.
Huh. So here is a book that's
bibliographically fascinating,
something of a puzzle to me.
This is a translation into
French of "Tom Jones."
Now in my view -- And I
haven't finished my study yet.
This is going to take
me several years.
But in my view, almost every
translation from English
into French is an abridgment
and almost every translation
from French into
English is an abridgment.
And partly because, if you're
reading it in another language,
how would you know that
what was being abridged,
and again this is an
opportunity for the bookseller
to calibrate how big he
wants the book to be.
In this case three
volumes bound into one,
three volumes duodecimo.
So this is an abridgment.
Trust me. It's also
a false imprint.
It's not published in London.
And it's using a
London bookseller's name
but the London bookseller has
nothing to do with this book.
And the thing that I haven't
been able to determine,
if there are any experts
out there, I'd be grateful
for the help of The
Baker Street Irregulars.
I cannot -- I'm having
difficulty telling
if the paper is Swiss, which
would lead me to believe
that it was printed at the STN,
the Societe typographique
de Neuchatel,
or if the paper is French,
in which case I believe it's
most likely printed Leon.
So paper moves back and forth a
lot and it's a little bit hard
to tell, but the idea is
this ain't what it seems.
It looks complete to those
who don't know but it's not.
It's an abridgment.
So as you will know,
the three voyages
of Cook are signal moments
in the history of
human exploration.
And as you will know, Cook
tragically dies on the shore
of Hawaii and in
the third voyage
and when the crew comes
back they're desperate
to have the official account.
And when the official account
is published one fine June day
in three volumes large quarto
with the volume underneath
that you can see the Atlas
volume because there are
so many cuts, so
many engravings,
the charts of navigation
and so on.
These three volumes go for
four and a half guinea.
The press run is 2000.
In the mid afternoon of the
third day of sale, the third day
of sale in June 1784,
they sell the last copy
and begin printing
the second edition.
Do you think this was of
fashionable commodity?
Do you think that the upper
classes had to have this book?
Well, no less the middling
sort had to have the book too
and immediately there follows
the first of a whole series
of abridgments of the third
voyage of Captain Cook,
this one published
in four volumes,
each volume comprising six
parts, 24 parts in all.
They make no bones about the
fact that it's an abridgment,
as you can see, and you
can follow the progress
of this along merely by
looking at the direction line,
which will tell you in
an unabashed way exactly
where they are in the progress
of this coming out in parts.
Will it surprise anyone
by this juncture to note
that they had the
subscribers all lined up
and already paying in advance?
No. No. So the reason why
this is issued in parts is
because the first part can be
printed the first day of sale
and be available by the
second day and they can begin
to satisfy all the subscribers
by the end of the week
because it's only one
fascicle in the six by four set
of fascicles that they're going
to use for the whole thing.
This is ingenuous.
Many of you will never heard
of a bookseller named
George Kearsley
who we saw earlier the
Beauties of Johnson.
Here you see that it's
an unabashed abridgment.
Right there it says the
first word an "abridgment"
of Captain Cook's last voyage
and the plate of the death
of Cook right in
the frontispiece,
the portal into the
sensational story.
And Kearsley publishes his
abridgment for four shillings.
That's the second one.
And here, note the
rhetoric of the abridgment.
Here, it is an undoubted fact
that not one person in 50 can
with convenience or
propriety make the purchase,
however eager the
curiosity pursue it
but we will accommodate
you, gentle reader.
We will help you.
We will make this
available to you.
It will be better,
faster, stronger.
You get the idea.
It's the same rhetoric
as you're getting
when Ortelius is abridged
and those three maps,
the star map [inaudible] and
the other map are added, right.
This is the same idea.
Somehow this is smaller
but somehow this is bigger.
Right? Because we're giving
you what you most want.
Then the third abridgment
comes out and I want you
to understand there
are 49 plates
in this abridgment and two maps.
This is not a cheap
print production.
I mean, it's relatively cheap
compared to paying 4.5 guineas
but this is not the
low-end of the market.
The low-end of the market
is yet to be exploited
and I won't iterate
every abridgment of Cook.
But this too is a highly
desirable production and raises
for us the question, I
believe, what does it mean
to read an abridgment
in the 18th century?
What does it mean to
undertake an abridgment?
It seems not at all to be
an occasion of shame either
to consume these things or
to produce these things.
Rather, it seems that
this is part and parcel
of the ordinary operation of the
marketplace and yet an aspect
of the operation of the
marketplace that we have again
and again missed for
a variety of reasons,
some of which I've
tried to delineate here.
So then in my view, the
history of the abridgment
of Cook's third voyage
becomes still more interesting
when we look at their
reprinting in America
and in other provincial markets.
So here we see those
three volumes
in a large octavo become 9
and 1/2 sheets in duodecimo
in Isaiah Thomas' [inaudible],
very, very interesting
because of the bespoke nature
of what an abridgment is
and his measure of the
carrying capacity of his market
or here we see in Philadelphia
an 18 [inaudible] production
in just seven sheets.
This is remarkable to me.
A city like Philadelphia
is going to deliver Cook
in such a truncated way.
Why? Because they can
and because he limits his
capital risk or even here,
this more extensive rendering
of Cook here in Boston,
the whole thing,
the three voyages
in just two volumes duodecimo.
Right? So here are
all the best bits.
It's not the CliffsNotes.
This is Cook's voyages but
it's Cook's voyages in a way
that you can afford and
that the undertaker can
afford to deliver to market.
So it seems to me, ladies and
gentleman, that the presence
of these abridgments in
the market need to occasion
in us a rethinking of how
we conduct literary history
and ought to, I think,
in us revive our sense
of how essential bibliography
and book history can be
to understanding the
reception history of books.
A caution, you cannot get most
of this information
out of catalogs.
There is no substitute
for the haptic knowledge
of holding the book in your hand
and examining it
with your own eyes.
Oftentimes, the abridgments
are not cataloged as such
and so you need to
really look at the books.
And if you really want to
understand how they're made and,
above all, what their
production values actually are,
you need to look
at a lot of books.
Graham Pollard famously said,
you know nothing about books
until you have examined
with your own hands
and your own eyes
5000 hand-press books.
So we need to restore, as
librarians, as scholars,
as curators, as conservators,
we need to restore a sense
of the essential nature of
the haptic knowledge of books
as cultural objects that
can teach us again and again
that our old certainties are
false, that our old pictures
of the market and of
the way things were read
and understood are
at best partial.
As Mr. Shelley teaches
us, "We must learn
to imagine what we know."
Thank you very much, indeed.
[ Applause ]
I'd be very happy
to take questions.
Please.
>> I assume the law
changed at some point.
>> The law does change at
some point because if you try
to make an abridgment, they're
going to throw you in jail,
if it's not authorized.
Right, so copyright law
changes a great deal
in the 19th century.
But for the 18th century,
this is the practice.
Now it is true that the
stationer's company does have
ways of trying to marginalize
you if you operate outside
of the [inaudible] and taboos
of the guild but it's also true
that there are lots of people,
especially the provincial
booksellers
and the booksellers abroad, who
make abridgments all the time.
Scotland, Dublin, America,
and indeed once you get
outside the home counties,
none of these are, there are
no prosecutions for this.
>> My sister had a copy of
"Little Women," that I grew
up reading and it wasn't until
I was reading it to my daughter
that I realized that what she
had had was an abridged edition
and I have no memory of
it saying anywhere on it
that it was abridged
[inaudible] 20th century.
>> Sure. And so this abridged
edition of "Little Women"
that doesn't even call
attention to itself
as an abridgment is produced in
part for the very same reasons
that as it were my booksellers
were producing these abridged
editions because
they're cheaper,
because the capital
risk is delimited,
and because they're
less intimidating.
They seem to be friendlier
books, down formats, smaller,
less an investment of
your money and time.
And so why wouldn't you do that?
Yeah. Please.
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
[Inaudible] it's
a great question.
So let me just repeat
the gist of it.
Obviously, the whole thrust
of this argument is
somehow [inaudible]
because there's no
sort of perfect version
of "Robinson Crusoe" or
Moll Flanders in the sky
but rather we need to look at
what was actually happening
on the ground and how people
were reading their books.
Dare I say we need to do the
history of reading in part
from the material
objects themselves.
Reading is conditioned of
course by social practices
and I would never be a material
determinist but surely we need
to understand reading
practices as highly conditioned
by that beautiful and complex
equation between materialities
and the making of culturally
instantiated meanings.
And so we need to look at
what's actually happening and,
therefore, Dr. Kleiner [assumed
spelling] asks the question,
is it not the case that there's
some evidence of the reception
of these and some
kind of comparing.
And here, I feel like I often
felt as a child at the school
of the holy child Jesus standing
before the nuns and confessing,
in this regard I have
not done my homework
because this project is in
process and I haven't gone
to the review journals, the
Monthly and the Critical
and the Edinburgh to look
for these data points.
So they may be out there and
they may not be out there.
I don't know the answer, but
it's extremely salutary point
to make, is there any weighing
up of the abridgments of Cook
to say, oh, the Kearsley
is rubbish
but this other one
is really good
and you'll get much better
value for your money.
I would hope so.
But I don't know.
John.
>> I have a sort of
related question, Michael.
How much corroborating evidence
have you come up with thus far
for your assertion regarding
contemporary attitudes
about abridgments?
If I'm reading your
argument correctly
and I may have missed something,
the argument is running,
there were a whole
heck of a lot of them
and respected people were
doing them and, therefore,
attitudes toward
them were positive.
But the same could be said for,
and I may be wrong misreading
you, but the same could be said
for study guides today.
We have the learned Harold Bloom
writing the learned version
of CliffsNotes just as we
and there are vast numbers
of four separate editions of the
CliffsNotes for Jane Eyre alone
and four [inaudible] literature
guide and everything else.
Is this a 20th century attitude?
Is this an 18th century
attitude?
And is it in fact different?
>> That's a good question.
I would say that Harold Bloom
engages in this activity
because he has a disabled son,
a developmentally disabled
son who's going to be
in an institution for
the rest of his life
and this is how Bloom
intends to make sure
that his son never lacks the
support that he requires.
I think Bloom is in some ways
an outlier in doing this.
I think most of the people
who write the CliffsNotes
are impoverished postdocs
or graduate students.
I'm sorry.
But it's also true that
I have been looking
for derisory remarks
about these abridgments
and of course the original
publishing booksellers don't
like them except for when
they themselves commission the
abridgments as in that marvelous
consortium of the princes
of publishing in the middle
of the 18th century Miller,
Dodsley, Kearsley, and
so on, all who own shares
in the dictionary and they
know exactly what to do
and they know exactly who their
man is and exactly how to do it.
So I think an abridgment
is a really great thing
when you're going to
make money from it
and an abridgment is
not a really good thing
when somebody's going
to make money
from what you have
originally published.
And I think it's
as simple as that.
I think that we're a
bit idealistic and naive
when we think about what
somebody like Robert Dodsley,
how he may have thought about
his business undertakings.
His principal goal, mirabile
dictu, is to make money and,
sure, he understands
that he's going
to occupy a certain
stratum in the market
but within certain
behaviors that are forbidden,
he's going to do
just about all he can
to leverage his advantage, both
against his fellow booksellers
and to activate the consumer
habits of the public.
And so I have not found
any derisory comments
from either authors
or booksellers
about the world of abridgments.
And I think in many ways it's
akin to saying, hey, you know,
my article got syndicated
or, you know, hey,
this thing is reprinted
in another venue
and that's terrific and more
people will get to see it.
So for the most part I haven't
been able to find that sort
of material though I've
certainly been looking for it.
And Goldsmith, who, you know,
drinks a lot and gambles a lot,
does not in any way seem to
do this out of desperation,
for the most part, right.
We know that Johnson
appears at Goldsmith's door
and brings the money
to his creditors
because the bailiffs
are pacing up
and down in front of his door.
So maybe Goldsmith isn't the
best example but Smollett is not
in penury of any kind when he's
undertaking these abridgments,
to the best of my knowledge.
Johnson could have commissioned
the abridgment of the dictionary
to someone else very
easily but he does not.
So I think it's important
to say, you know,
people were undertaking
these abridgments
because they were
successful, you know.
The abridgers were making money.
The booksellers were
making money.
The publishing, you
know, the other sellers
of the abridgments
were making money.
This seems to me like win, win,
win all around but not part
of the collecting
practice of individuals
or cultural institutions,
inordinately low survival rates,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera,
and this to me is why, you know,
how can I say, oh, well
this has always been here
but we just haven't noticed.
Well, I think because of a
concatenation of a variety
of reasons, some of which
are about the survival
of material traces and some
of which are about the nature
of the cultural products
that are for projects
that our forebears
have undertaken.
>> The 19th in America you read
that people were ecstatic
thinking about the arrival
of a new Scott novel
from England.
Would this have been
abridged or stolen from Scott?
>> Well, that's a very
interesting question.
So the question is, you know,
people, we know, for instance,
let's just shift from Scott
to Dickens just for
a moment, right.
We know, for instance,
that people were waiting
on the dockside of
New York, right,
to see what happened
a little Nell, right.
You know, we know
that, you know,
the police were worried
there are so many people
on the dock waiting for
the ship to come in so
that someone could, you know,
break open the package
and read the passage.
And I won't spoil what
happens to little Nell
in case you don't know but many,
many unhappy people
left the dock that day.
Men were weeping.
But Dickens, of course,
undertakes his reading tour
precisely because he is furious
that the American
booksellers are making
so much money off his wit and
imagination and word craft
and he's making nothing.
So he'd says, damn it, I'm going
to undertake a reading tour
because I have this popularity
and I am going to find a way
to capitalize on it
because all the booksellers
who are publishing
my works are pirates.
And even Conan Doyle,
for instance, you know,
quite a bit later, Conan
Doyle comes to America
to undertake his reading
tour and his lecturing tour
for the very same reason.
The way that the American
copyright law is written
at that juncture is that
international copyright obtains
if the book is published first
in America and, of course,
that's not what happens most
of the time and, therefore,
these books are not protected
in the United States and,
therefore, authors find other
expedience in order to try
to capitalize on
their popularity.
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
So the question is, well,
if these abridgments
-- May I paraphrase?
If these abridgments are so
darn ubiquitous, Michael,
then surely there must
be some reflexivity
that they must affect the
cultural production of novels.
Perhaps. On the other hand,
we need to remember that,
for instance, when George
Eliot publishes "Middlemarch"
in those eight parts, she has
an incentive for prolixity.
I think "Middlemarch" is the
greatest novel ever published
in the English language.
Others may disagree,
maybe, but she has a reason
to make it be in eight parts.
That's what her contract says.
Dickens, you know, needs to get
to that 19th and
20th part, right.
Thackeray, you know, there's
a reason why "Vanity Fair" is
as long as it is or "Pendennis"
or the "The Virginians"
or even "The History of Henry
Esmond" for Pete's sake.
So it seems to me that there
are two contrary market forces
at work and I think
that the bird
in the hand is worth
a lot more than two
in the bush in this instance.
So I personally -- Again,
I've only been working on this
for about three years
and I think this requires
quite a sustained study.
I like to assure you it's not
the only thing I ever plan to do
with the rest of my life but
at the same time I do believe
that this requires
further study.
And the question of
how it translates
into 19th century practice,
I leave to my betters,
many of whom are
sitting in this audience.
Please.
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Is it correct to assume
that because these are less
expensive print products
and occupy a different
stratum in the marketplace
that the production
values are inferior
to the original production
values?
Is that fair paraphrase?
No, not at all and that's one
of the reasons why I wanted
in particular to show
you that third abridgment
of Cook's final voyage because
with 49 charts and two cuts
in the book this is a
remarkable, you know,
high-value production.
It is true that some of them
are on lesser paper, which is,
you know, most of the cost
of producing the book,
but by no means all.
I would say that the "Tom Jones"
for instance that I showed you,
now it happens to be a very nice
copy in the Houghton Library
and the binding is
in some ways risible.
It's a collector's binding, very
rare thing to find an abridgment
in a collector's binding,
speaking to the point we
were addressing earlier.
But no, I find that for the most
part the production values are
quite high with some
notable exceptions.
And I would say, too, it
would be injudicious of us
to compare printing in Hartford,
Connecticut to printing
in London at the same time
because the resources just
aren't the same, right.
So we need to be a little bit
careful about comparing apples
to apples and not
comparing apples to oranges.
I think if we were to sort of
say, well, how are you going
to evaluate that Hartford,
Connecticut production,
we'd need to compare it
to original publications
that were also part
of provincial presses
in New England and we would see
that indeed this one is as good
as anything that's
coming off those presses.
So again, I think that these
are of course price points
but there are certainly
theories about the market.
And I think that to make
the books unattractive
with a few exceptions.
I mean we saw that those
halfpenny half sheet epitomes
of "Jure Divino" are
nasty productions, right.
The paper is bad.
Of course, the paper
trade in England is bad
at the time but the
paper is bad.
The press work isn't
particularly good.
The wood cut on the
cover is stolen.
It's reversed from
the second edition
of "True-born Englishman"
and so on.
So it's not always the case.
There are times when -- But I
think that in the case of the
"Jure Divino" it's
because of speed.
It's not because so much --
It's not merely because
of price point.
It's because speed is of
the essence at that moment
in getting the product to
market and that's, you know,
you can make it, you can make
it good and you can make it fast
and you can make it cheap,
but you can't make
it all three, right.
You have to choose.
You can make a good and fast
but it's not cheap, right.
You can make it cheap and good
but then it's not going
to be fast and so on.
So you have this
triangle of value
and you can only ever have
two of them at the same time.
And to me that's a very
useful heuristic for thinking
about the book trade
more generally.
Please. And then Steve.
Go ahead.
>> You talk about the value
of speed when creating a book.
Did book sellers or writers ever
publish their own abridgments
or were abridgments
something that [inaudible]?
>> It's interesting.
Well, certainly Goldsmith
abridges his own abridgments.
Johnson abridges
his own writings.
But by and large --
It's a good question.
By and large, as
far as I know, not.
Now one of the issues is
I've been searching mostly
in the manuscripts division
of the British Library
for the agreements for
undertaking abridgments.
As you might imagine,
they're not well calendared
and they're hard to find.
But for the most part, we
don't see authors undertaking
abridgments of their own works.
Let's take for instance in works
of science because they say,
well, I'm, you know, I'm trying
to do work or in the case
of novelists, because these
abridgments, generally speaking,
are meant to be sure bet,
it's the reprint trade
and they're undertaking
possibility of writing a novel
or a new play for which the
income they would receive is
much greater than for
undertaking the abridgment.
So again, I think
this is a marketplace
and we haven't figured
abridgments as part
of the marketplace
either in authorship
or in the bookselling world
or in the consumption
of cultural goods.
And I do think that the
more we countenance this,
the more we'll know, and we'll
get a fuller thicker picture
of what's actually
happening in the culture.
Let's have the final question.
You need to eat.
>> Did it work the other way?
Would the American author expect
to see his novel abridgment
[inaudible] see that happening?
>> Well, in the 19th
century, of course,
the only novel that's
published for a long time
by an American printer is
when Ben Franklin produces
his edition of "Clarissa"
and that goes, "Pamela," I'm
sorry, of "Pamela" and that goes
so badly that it's more than
30 years before a new novel is
printed in the United
States, as it were.
So for the most part,
those longer print productions
are produced in England anyway
and so then they become part of
the ecosystem in a normal way.
I have kept you a long time.
I'm very grateful for
your attentiveness.
I would be glad to answer
questions for those of you
who still have remaining
questions or comments
or indeed excoriations
and I thank you very much
for coming this evening.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.